[Musique]
à washington au côté du président
kennedy le commandant shepard a trouvé
la consécration de son exploit
[Musique]
le film pris par la caméra placée dans
la cabine permet de revivre tous les
instincts de cet exploit et en
particulier celui impressionnant de
l'apparition dans un hublot d'une sphère
à l'aspect taux monte à 180 km
la terre félicitez décor est acclamé
alan shepard avec le jour de gloire d'un
héros national
[Musique]
les perdants gary cooper le cinéma perd
sans doute l'un de ces grands noms mais
le public des salles obscures pairs
comme un frère c'était en effet depuis
30 ans le cowboy bien aimé l'un de ses
héros auquel va tout de suite la
sympathie quand la guerre sur 20 il fut
l'un de ses artistes ambassadeurs de
l'amitié qui a l'air sous tous les ciels
soutenir le moral des armées au combat
c'est qu'il était le héros type de ces
épopées édifiante qui nous rendent pour
un jour la fraîcheur et l'enthousiasmé
de l'adolescence et il l'était avec
cette simplicité qui trouve tout de
suite le chemin du coeur il meurt à 60
ans après avoir tourné près de 100 films
il sera toujours le plus courageux des
trois lanciers du bengale toujours
l'adorable le modeste l'extravagant mr
deeds l'arrêt cooper est mort pas tout à
fait
[Musique]
la fièvre d'alger n'est pas apparente
mais dans le tort une partie de
l'escadron méditerranéenne avec le
porte-avions lafayette reste un arrêt
tandis que de rigoureuses mesures de
sécurité sont maintenues et que 28 mille
hommes des forces de l'ordre mènent une
surveillance pour empêcher la
recrudescence des attentats activistes
paris n'a pas été épargné une flambée
d'attentats au plastique a fait des
dégâts et des victimes au palais royal
où les fenêtres du ministère des
affaires culturelles qu'occupe monsieur
andré malraux ont volé en éclats et rue
simonds d'horreur à la porte d'un
conseiller municipal et où les criminels
ont signé leur hâte
[Musique]
en plein jour deux autres explosions se
sont produites dans le quartier de
l'opéra l'une rue des pyramides dans les
bureaux d'un journal et qui a blessé
deux passants une autre où l'on a relevé
cinq blessés avenue de l'opéra bhl des
esprits fossé n'hésitent plus devant le
crime
c'est dans ce climat troublé que le
maréchal lyautey a fait sa dernière
halte sur le chemin du retour
le corps du créateur du maroc moderne à
passer sous la voûte de la rrq de
l'étoile sa première nuit de paris
le lendemain ils étaient solennellement
conduit jusqu'à cette nécropole des
invalides que la patrie reconnaissante
réserve assez grand soldat mais si noble
que puisse être le décor à faire
finalement à ses cendres l'esprit et les
actes de lyautey ne saurait être
ensevelies et le général de gaulle en
citant une de ses phrases prophétique a
su tirer la leçon de son oeuvre immense
il y a lieu de prévoir 10 est il qu'en
un temps plus ou moins lointain
l'afrique du nord évolue et vivant de sa
vie autonome se détachera de la
métropole ils font qu'à ce moment là a
ajouté t-il et ce doit être le but de
suprême de toute notre politique
cette séparation se fin sans douleur et
que les africains continuent toujours de
se tourner vers la france
si l'histoire a failli aux voeux du
maréchal en arrachant à cette terre
marocaine qu'il n'aurait jamais voulu
quitter la flamme qui l'animait est
vivant l'exemple qu'il donne à reste bon
la leçon qu'il a légué demeure fait
qu'au 27 années après sa mort années qui
virent se transformer de fond en comble
les conditions de son époque comme l'a
dit le président de la république
le maréchal n'a pas fini de servir la
france
les grands problèmes de l'heure ne faut
pas oublier les eaux et les pigeons à
paris par exemple sont un problème il y
a trente pigeons bien sûr ils ont des
amis plein de sollicitude et fanta ce
qui fait partie du pittoresque locale
mais un regard il faut tenir compte des
dégâts qu'ils causent aux monuments
vénérable dont ils sont devenus la plaie
quotidienne sans parler des injures
causés aux gloires nationales
on conçoit que les édiles se soit
inquiété de leur dégradation et et tenté
déjà dans exils et quelques-uns mais ils
reviennent
ajoutez à cela que les gardiens du
patrimoine national ne sont pas ça la
dre les pigeons de paris aux gémonies
les automobilistes aussi et les amoureux
alors alors il s'est trouvé deux
vilaines âmes pour faire plus que
souhaiter leur disparition
la précipiter quelques graines
empoisonnées ont ainsi provoqué l'agonie
d'innocents visait
méthode qui soulève l'indignation des
amis des bêtes
alors in it raconte nice qui est il les
pigeons et les sacrifie avec douceur
c'est le terme officiel l'immigraton
londres où l'on d'indigènes les
bâtiments publics d'un produit qui
éloigne les oiseaux ou bien vienne ou
patiemment des spécialistes vont
stériliser les oeufs dans les nids la
décision en tout cas devient urgente
sinon on peut augurer que les ennemis
des pigeons vont passer à l'action
les hommes étant le bricolage et la
patience au service du noël longtemps
contenue
[Musique]
les autres peut-être employant les
grands moyens et il est des évocations
tellement tories an d'écart le premier
grand prix international de l'année
comptant pour le championnat du monde
des conducteurs défiguration de la
victoire stirling moss descend de sa
voiture comme s'il était déjà bac c'est
bientôt le départ que va donner louis
chiron un connaisseur
il sont partis c'est ce bolide rouge
vert et blanc entament la ronde qui va
durer près de trois heures dans les rues
de la ville une rendent très pénible
sous un soleil de plomb sur un circuit
très tournante et pénible même poster
the most numéro 20 qui est en tête le
champion britannique au volant d'une
lotus pourtant moins rapide que les
ferrari donne un véritable récital de bi
le tac
on n'avait pas vu mieux depuis peu mieux
citons encore aujourd'hui que stirling
moss n'ai jamais été champion du monde
alors qu'il est de loin le meilleur de
tous les pilotes de grand prix
champion du monde il le sera peut-être
cette année en tout cas après sa
victoire à monte-carlo tous les espoirs
lui sont permis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rencontre au sommet du football français
au parc des princes 40000 spectateurs
entassés dans les tribunes transpirant
comme dans un bain turc attentes de ce
match un champion de france
de fait le vainqueur de la rencontre va
prendre une sérieuse option sur le titre
1961 pour le moment le racing maillot
blanc culotte noire et monaco dans son
corps toutes premières escarmouches
locale mais c'est monsieur l'arbitré
accorde un penalty à monaco quelle belle
le manque pour la plus grande joie des
spectateurs décidément sans pitié une
fois n'est pas coutume le public
parisien soutien dressing et c'est
peut-être pour cela que les joueurs de
la capitale fournissent leur meilleur
match de la saison
voilà comment on amène un fort joli but
après un premier quart d'heure de jeu
plein de promesses qui sont déjà presque
champion de france dans les gradins
monaco ne baisse pas les bras loin de là
ce qui donne encore beaucoup plus de
relief à la rencontre cette attaque de
l'ailier gauche carlier aurait peut-être
fait mouche si le crâne dégarni de roger
marche ne s'était trouvé sur la
trajectoire de la balle
elle revient dans le camp parisien cette
balle mais roger marche aussi et avec
lui toute la défense du racing
[Applaudissements]
on ne s'affole pas dans les tribunes à
quoi
[Applaudissements]
d'autant que la victoire du racing dont
les attaques sont plus tranchantes et
quasi certaine en appui au bon moment
sur la caméra pour fixer le second but
petit exploit technique de vente sam
affolement dans la défense monégasque
ujlaky et bien placé
[Applaudissements]
c'est maintenant le festival des joueurs
parisiens qui font marquer un troisième
but et avec cette victoire le racing est
déjà presque champion de france
[Musique]